The Witcher nods to the conjunction of
the Spheres ithlean's prophecy and where
witchers come from but doesn't explain
any of it the new prequel series blood
origin answers many of those questions
and raises more warning spoilers ahead
in the time of The Witcher the continent
is a hodgepodge of social political and
religious groups subject to an endless
cycle of war and racial conflict much of
that Strife comes as a result of human
machinations as the many human nations
of the continent are prone to infighting
just as often as they are prejudice
against elves dwarves and the like one
of the settings most enduring and
poignant features is the abundance of
Elven ruins and artifacts across the
land over which Humanity builds their
Empires and attempts to recreate old
Elvish Magics my elders worked with
humans
got robbed of all they had
and when they fought back they were
slaughtered yet in The Witcher blood
origin Humanity has yet to arrive on the
continent and in its place the Elven
Empires proved themselves every bit as
bloodthirsty as their eventual human
successors the series begins with three
major Elven kingdoms uniting under one
Banner with zentreya as its capital city
the unification is no feat of diplomacy
but rather the act of a few scheming
power mad individuals specifically
baller and Eridan the new unified empire
is built on a shaky Foundation as a
result this period is known in Canon as
a golden age in Elven history and yet
even then it was a violent tenuous time
by the series end the death of an
empress the shattering of dimensional
barriers and a peasant Uprising all
bring the so-called golden age to an
ugly end
though they've yet to properly arrive in
The Witcher to Hound Siri and plague
geralt's dreams the wild Hunt is one of
the greatest threats in The Witcher
Cannon and is likely to end up as the
series overarching villains in the
subkovsky novels video games and other
media the wild Hunt is one of the
primary groups responsible for series
constant Pursuit and nomadic lifestyle
they want Siri's unique power that comes
from her Elder blood a power that is
prophecied to either end the world or
save it all of their efforts begin in
the final moments of The Witcher blood
origin when baller betrays Eridan and
casts him into an unknown Dimension the
elf seems doomed to a slow demise on a
dead alien world but it's precisely that
Exile that causes Eridan alongside his
band of loyal soldiers to begin
transforming into the Fearsome wild Hunt
eredon's singular determination allows
him to survive Exile discover the
secrets to interdimensional travel and
return into the continent as the king of
the wild Hunt using Advanced magic found
only on other worlds Eridan and his band
evolve into something more than simple
Raiders wielding Frost magic and
commanding Elemental beasts they become
terrifying figures who haunt the dreams
of folk from the continent and Beyond
The Witcher blood origin establishes the
origin for several major moments in the
franchise's lore the biggest and most
important are the conjunction and the
creation of the first Witcher but the
series also finds time to sprinkle in
the origins of smaller characters that
are destined as more hardcore fans will
undoubtedly know to become Central
figures in Witcher lore one such figure
is ithylene who appears in the series
for just a few short scenes as a poor
little girl who happens to have psychic
Visions as it turns out that little girl
eventually grows into the most famous
seer in history whose most famous
prophecy points to Siri as the cause of
Armageddon in the final moments of the
series Kathleen offers Ayla the Lark a
prophecy regarding her child and its
descendants as ominous as it sounds it's
nothing compared to what she'll predict
just a few years later unlike so many
other oracles an alarming amount of
ithlean's prophecies end up coming true
and so her writings become almost sacred
texts in the world of The Witcher many
of the major decisions made by kings
queens and mages in the time of geralt
come as a result of ithlean's words and
their ever-present Doom another minor
character in The Witcher blood origin
who closes out the series in an
impactful way is avalak for the vast
majority of the series The Young elf is
merely a simple Mages Apprentice a
stuttering Lackey with no discernible
importance Beyond his meager station a
surprising rise to prominence comes
after saving Empress Maryland from a
would-be assassin Maryland has no idea
what events she's setting in motion by
promoting overlock and granting him
access to higher level magical research
nor how he will one day play a major
part in the story of geralt and Siri I
need you to learn how to open gateways
to new worlds this is insane
I'm going to die as fans of the novels
and video games will know avalock is an
ancient Elven Mage with an unparalleled
knowledge of interdimensional travel Who
eventually becomes series mentor and
bodyguard in the game The Witcher 3 it's
thanks to avalock that Siri is able to
evade the wild Hunt for so long and it's
only through him that she's able to
understand the truth of her powers and
finally Master them by Awakening
avalock's potential Empress marowen
unknowingly sets in motion a series of
events that culminate in series survival
and therefore enables Siri to play
whatever cataclysmic role she's meant to
the world of The Witcher blood origin
seems harsh and violent enough for the
series first few episodes but its finale
takes everything to an extreme new level
by ushering in the conjunction of the
Spheres the conjunction is perhaps the
single most important event in The
Witcher Canon and even when shown in the
series its full importance goes Untold
the finale shows the conjunction's first
moments describing it as a shattering of
space and time a tearing of the veils
Between Worlds but even that grandiose
narration doesn't begin to cover it
almost instantly the conjunction
transforms the continent from a place of
relative uniformity and stability into a
terrifying Savage land where dozens to
hundreds of different species of
monsters humans and elves included war
with each other for Supremacy gone are
the days when a peasant's greatest
concerns were taxes and blight instead
they are replaced with the existential
Terror of vampires basilisks hikimores
and leshes the establishment of the
various Witcher schools is a direct
response to this sudden influx of
monstrous beasts and without the
conjunction there would be no witchers
around which to build a franchise
as any longtime fan of The Witcher
franchise can tell you the real monsters
aren't the beings with sharp claws
stingers and Rotting Flesh they're the
very people around us the regular
citizens who suddenly resort to ghoulish
acts of violence and selfishness that
humanity is the real monster is one of
the central themes that guide every
aspect of The Witcher franchise in a
clever stroke of World building
zubkovsky chose to introduce humans to
the continent at the same time as the
more obvious monsters making the
creation of the witchers a dual
necessity in the latter half of The
Witcher blood origin finale the
conjunction of the Spheres brings
Humanity to the continent forever
changing its landscape in the finale an
Elven fisherman stumbles upon a
shipwreck where passengers speak no
Elvish and bear smooth rounded ears
those first human settlers though
unintentionally start a process on the
continent that in many ways resembles an
infection spreading from Nation to
Nation tearing them down to continue
feeding and increasing their numbers
one of the more Curious new additions to
The Witcher lore in Netflix is The
Witcher is the presence of the monoliths
strange black pillars of stone that
Harbor deep Secrets relating to Magic
and the conjunction of the Spheres the
video games have their own monoliths
which seem unrelated and the books have
no mention of them at all making them a
novel invention for the Netflix series
they pop up again and again in The
Witcher forming the basis of istrid's
research interfering with series Power
and even summoning several entirely new
species of Monsters the mysterious
structures return in The Witcher blood
origin and like other important facets
of the universe their true nature and
origin are revealed more fully in the
series it turns out that the monoliths
are Dwarven Creations only controlled by
the elves because of their conquest of
the dwarves in their territory their
magic is ancient predating even Elvish
magic and is intrinsically tied to the
land and the underlying properties of
the dimension itself just as the
monoliths withstood the magical
experimentation Of The Elves and endured
until the time of humanity they also
endured throughout the days of Dwarven
dominion and Elvish Conquest making them
some of the only unchanging features of
the continent's landscape the world of
The Witcher is chock full of fascinating
characters creatures coalitions and
conflicts that make for excellent story
material but at the end of the day the
reason we're here is The Witcher himself
geralt of Rivia he and his fellow cat
eyed sword-slinging Brethren give the
franchise its namesake and our
subkovsky's primary invention The
Witcher blood origin is fully aware of
this fact which is why much of its story
is dedicated to the creation and
eventual destruction of the continent's
first Witcher the first Witcher wasn't
created by any organization in response
to encroaching monsters and it even
predates the conjunction of the Spheres
instead the first Witcher is made for
killing one single Monster although the
process of mutating young boys into
witchers eventually becomes standardized
the first attempt is anything but the
owl is laid on the dirt floor of a cave
given a mix of herbs and infused with
the blood of the most convenient monster
the transformation ultimately consumes
him and leads to his death and how the
process was revived and eventually
streamlined is still unknown
bookending The Witcher blood origin are
prophecies from The Young ithlean the
first prophecy centers around the Lark
in her Quest but the second prophecy the
one that comes at the tail end of the
finale seems tailor-made for geralt and
Siri in particular one invocation of a
seed Bears a great portent
first note of a song that ends of times
this is almost certainly a direct
reference to Siri's Elder blood and her
eventual role in the ending of the world
this final Prophecy of the series Echoes
the most famous of ithlean's predictions
in the books and games known in geralt's
time as simply ithlean's prophecy it
foretells the ending of the world all
centered around Elder blood Elder blood
flows through Siri which makes the girl
perhaps the greatest asset to anyone in
the Spheres who has a stake in
Armageddon like ethelene's prophecy this
prediction from the blood origin is
likely what will set in motion the
series of events that lead to Future
Generations fear of those with elder
blood
as The Witcher blood origin concludes
chanaki implores yaskir to sing the song
of the seven referring to the tale of
y'all the Lark and the five companions
she wants the famous Bard to spread the
tail far and wide rekindling the fire of
Hope among elvendom that the Lark and
Company first breathed to life over a
millennium ago
tasked by the mysterious and god-like
shanaki to sing the song of the seven
across the continent yaskir emerges from
the series with a new purpose one meant
to tip the scales of power toward the
side of elves chanaki's nature and
ultimate motivations are unclear so it's
difficult to determine exactly why she
brought this tale back to life or what
will come from it but regardless it will
certainly mean more for yaskir the sect
of elves known as these quietel and
therefore the state of the world for
geralt and Siri in future seasons of The
Witcher although the majority of The
Witcher blood origin is set long before
the time of geralt and Siri there are
two brief sequences set in their era one
at the series very start and one at its
end and those few moments we're able to
learn a little about the current state
of the continent and its warring
inhabitants for one thing we know that
the wars in the northern continent have
for some reason attracted attention from
extra dimensional beings hence shanaki's
involvement it's also confirmed that
shanaki will be in more Witcher projects
going forward both she and the song of
the seven are likely to appear in The
Witcher and future seasons in addition
the scene in which we first find yes
gear says a lot about the current state
of things he is apparently regarded as a
folk hero the noble Sandpiper rescuer of
elves and is even beloved enough to
Warrant his rescue from Human capture by
an entire company of squatel it seems
since we last left yes gear and the rest
of our heroes in The Witcher season 2 2
the continent has moved forward
elevating yes gear along with it